Okay, moving on to item D, initiation of an amendment to the zoning code, zoning map and
general plan and land use map to identify appropriate locations for truck intensive
industrial uses and provide reasonable development standards to protect neighboring residential
neighborhoods from the impacts of excessive truck traffic.
Mr. Fresk, can I have the staff report on this item?
Yes, thank you Madam Mayor and Council members as the Council's aware we've had several land
use entitlement applications that have come before the city that actually are truck intensive.
They require a lot of vehicle trips with trucks and I believe we're all aware of the
impacts that truck traffic has, it has an impact on traffic congestion, it has an impact
on air pollution, it has an impact on our infrastructure and oftentimes these impacts
have a disproportionate effect on our residents, particularly residential communities.
When we talk about truck intensive uses, we've identified some of those in the staff report,
I'll mention them just for the, particularly for the benefit of the public.
But we're looking at truck and transport uses, truck and semi-trailer storage yards,
heavy equipment, sales and rental, auto auction, salvage yards, contractor storage yards,
and another use is warehouse and distribution centers as well.
And there are three different areas that have, that we've identified that really could benefit
from clarity if we go back and analyze the main land use documents that we use to,
when we're reviewing entitlements, our zoning ordinance, our general plan land use map,
and our design guidelines.
So we've identified some areas that really need clarification as well as the need to
really go back and look comprehensively at the city and identify what areas make sense
for these types of uses and what areas don't.
And what design standards can we, can we apply that really, again, at clarity, not only for
staff in applying the city's, the city council's vision toward these types of uses, but also
for the development community.
So they're clear when they look at our code, they have a clear understanding of where these
types of uses can go.
This evening, what we're recommending is that the city council initiate an effort for us
to conduct a study and look at all of those documents that I just mentioned to those land
use documents and to do so in a way that really addresses the concerns that have been expressed
by the council.
I think there's, there is an understanding that this type of, these types of uses and
the truck uses that are generated from this do have an impact, a negative impact on the
public's health, safety and welfare.
And so, so we are looking for a direction to do that as far as that initiation process.
And of course, that process would come back through after our analysis to the planning commission
for review and recommendation, and then back again to the city council.
In addition to that analysis and that initiation, we're also recommending the adoption of an
urgency ordinance that would apply a moratorium on those types of uses.
It would basically put a pause on those types of uses right now while we conduct this analysis.
And then once we do that, we bring it back up to the city council.
We make the council that makes whatever changes are appropriate.
The moratorium would then be lifted.
And we would then apply those new standards to any applications.
I would like to make mention to you that of all those different uses that I identified
on that list, I do want to call out the issue of warehouse and distribution centers because
that's an important distinction here.
The moratorium really doesn't address warehouse and distribution centers.
And the reason why that is, is because there's two areas that are specified in the city where
you can have those types of uses.
It's the Miraloma Overlay Zone and the Algomonta.
So outside of that, no one can come in and do distribution of warehousing.
So we felt that the code already addresses that.
But the draft urgency ordinance that is presented before you this evening does give the city
council flexibility if you want to modify those overlay zones.
So if there's a project that for whatever reason has a tremendous community benefit is located
in an area that the council seems appropriate, the council has the ability to still approve
that type of project.
So you're not handcuffed or limited by that moratorium in that way.
So if the council does adopt an urgency ordinance, it would require a four fifth vote to do that.
It is good for 45 days, which means that because our study would take much longer than that,
we're probably looking at approximately a year to do that.
We would bring back to you, most likely in February, a request to extend that moratorium.
And there's the ability to extend that twice.
So that essentially concludes my presentation.
We have received, again, letters regarding this particular item.
We've received approximately 10 letters from the community in support of this action,
including the moratorium.
We've also received one letter from Jonathan Chardlow.
He is representing a property where there's currently an auto auction, it's insurance auto auction,
which is located on Pyrite north of the 60 there, they're asserting and requesting that
because they are in the entitlement process that they be exempted from the moratorium.
So that's their request, as well as requesting a community workshop to be held.
And then there's one letter that was submitted by Robert Evans, he's the executive director
of the National Association of Industrial and Office Properties.
And it's a letter of opposition, particularly for the moratorium.
And all of those letters have been provided to the city council for your review.
And that concludes my presentation.
I'm, of course, available for any questions you might have.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mr. President.
Any questions for staff?
I would.
Okay.
During the pause, what happens to pretty much all the situation?
That's a very good question.
So if an application has already been submitted prior to the, prior to the initiation, the
moratorium, I should say, prior to the application of that.
One thing on those types of applications, they cannot receive approval.
So they can't go to the planning commission for action or the city council.
However, it would be up to the applicant in that case to continue the processing of that
application, but it would be at their risk and at their cost.
So if they can, they can just sit and pause and not move any further, or they can continue
to move through the process, we can continue to evaluate it and so forth at their costs
and at their risk.
But there would be no assurance at the end of the day that they could even receive approval
because the standards and the requirements may change.
So that's why we say it's at a certain risk and at their risk.
So that's sort of what happens now for folks who want to come in and apply after the moratorium,
we won't accept that application for these types of uses.
And assuming they're, I don't think they would be operating at the moment, so it wouldn't
apply that.
No.
They wouldn't be operating anyway, right?
Okay.
Thank you.
Hey, Councilman Burksen.
Yeah.
You know, I just want to make a couple comments.
I received a couple of correspondence about this one from the attorney representing the
IAA, the insurance auto auction.
And the second one, I think it said galiano, I'm not sure it was galiano trucking or however
they called it, both of which wanted to be exempted from this because they, at least the
insurance auto auction one, they've had an application in the city for a couple of
years.
And also I want to make clear that I had a meeting with the representation with the city
staff a week or so ago about that, that entire area of off the pyrite gave some kind of suggestions
so that they were moving in a forward direction.
So I mean, I don't know how the rest of the council feels about whether or not we exclude
those two from the moratorium.
Those are the only two that I know of that asked for exclusions.
I know it's time we evaluate this in its entirety citywide.
This is a great time to do it, you know, it needs to be done.
I want to put somebody out who's already invested time and money and, you know, it's not like
they're up against the clock where they didn't perform within their, you know, period
of time before this is just, they want to continue their process.
And those two projects I think at the end of the day are still going to come in front
of council for final approval, whatever they decide to do down the road.
So I just think that maybe we should clarify or decide whether or not we, these particular
ones or any particular ones that already have applications in the city that have been working
on it.
So does staff have any idea if there's other developments or developers or owners that
have something in the system here at City Hall for getting approvals for this?
Those are the projects that I'm aware of.
Just those two, right.
But what, and because of that, perhaps if that's the direction that City Council wants to go
and you alluded to it, Council Member Burksen, is to just indicate that the moratorium would
not apply to any project that is currently being processed where there's already been
an application submitted.
That's one avenue that the...
Well, since there's only two of them, I'm comfortable with that, if Council concurs with adding
that to this, at this point, again, they're going to still have to come and get approvals
and we can still deny it.
So it's not as if it's a free pass, but they are in process.
So I would hate to see that just get stopped just because we...
How long have they been in process when did they submit their application?
Oh, goodness.
The insurance auto auction, it's been probably two years officially since they formally
applied.
So it's been some time.
I think it's the Galiano Trestor, how about the Galiano Trestor?
I'm not sure how long they've been in process.
Galiano Trestor?
Well, does anyone else have any other questions for staff?
Okay.
Ms. Wasko?
Yes.
I do have several letters.
This first letter is actually from Joanna Arroyo, Jessica Saccito, Jorge Saccito, Clara
Saccito, and Faraz Rizvi.
I'm writing to express my support for imposing a moratorium on the expansion of truck intensive
uses in Aruba Valley.
The last few years have seen a massive increase in warehouses across our region, which has
resulted in an extraordinarily high number of trucks moving through our community, causing
traffic and releasing deadly emissions.
We urge the Council to approve the moratorium to study the impacts and move towards a green
and just economy.
It is crucial to protect the lives and health of our community members and the future of
our city's success and well-being.
This letter is from Donia de Ramon.
We urge the Council to approve this moratorium to study the impacts and move towards a green
and just economy.
This is even more important and urgent now during the COVID-19 pandemic that has disproportionately
impacted black and Latino communities and those with pre-existing health conditions.
This is your opportunity to vote in support of keeping our community safer and preventing
more negative health impacts and lethal deaths in our community.
I urge you to vote in support of this truck moratorium.
This is from Hank Truba.
I'm asking the City Council to set a temporary moratorium pursuant to government code sections
65858 regarding the establishment of truck intensive uses in the industrial park.
The area includes medium to heavy duty use.
This temporary moratorium will allow city agencies to come up with a solution that would
be in the best interest of the community.
This will also give them more time to explore the best options.
This letter is from Kim Gerald Johnson.
I was so pleased to see this item on the agenda, the constant pressure in our city to turn valuable
land into truck related uses that bring few jobs, no sales tax and little to no increase
in property tax has to be addressed and I'm glad the Council is proposing to do so.
It is just like the pressure our city faces with regards to warehouse uses.
As with the warehouses we have done our part, sacrificing our future as a city so property
owners and trucking operations can make their money is not right.
If they had their way, we would probably have a truck stop at every off ramp on the 60 freeway
from country village to Peddley to pyrite to Rubido Boulevard.
I don't think anyone believes that is a good thing.
At the same time, the way our ordinance is currently written, it gives the mistaken impression
that we allow and welcome these uses.
We need amendments to our zoning ordinances that make it clear where these uses would be
allowed and what would be needed to allow them.
That would be better for our city and for property owners and business people.
Meanwhile, these uses should be put on hold so we can make the changes that are right for
Herupa Valley.
Again, I say bravo for being forward thinking and addressing this important issue.
This last letter is from Penny Newman.
I'm writing in support of item number 17D initiating an amendment to the zoning code zoning
map and general plan and land use map to identify appropriate locations for truck intensive
industrial uses and produce reasonable development standards to protect neighboring residential
neighborhoods from the impacts of excessive truck traffic.
This seems to be a reasonable measure that would allow the city time to explore the impacts
of truck traffic upon our local neighbors.
I believe it is in the best way to meet the needs of the community while still protecting
the health and well-being of our residents.
I urge you to vote yes to approve this measure.
Madam Mayor, if I could, I would just think it'd end to be clear.
Another project did come to mind.
It's the Havana J&B transport operation where there was, that was actually brought to the
city council and that was denied and they have reapplied for conditionally used permits.
So I'm just thinking that that is another that would fall within the scope of this.
So it's just not the two that we talked about.
Where's that one located?
It's on rubido and around 28th Street, I believe.
The one from the insurance auto auctions on high rate where the asset pits are, there
are very few uses that can happen there so that's...
I have an idea.
The reason to give them the ability to continue on with their city application.
The Galliano one I presumed is over there by the winery, so that's also rural-ish.
But I don't know if this is the one on rubados by any residential.
Is there anyone that we denied, they're reapplying.
So there's three applicants that we own.
The Galliano if it's by the wine area, the winery, there is no application at that point.
And I think my recollection of that, that may not fall within the scope of this because
I think it's business park as opposed to warehouses and if there are, that would fall
under the council's flexibility.
So I don't see them being impacted by that, but the two for certain that would be impacted
is the Havana, JMB transport, off of rubido, and the IAA, the auction operation, off of
the pyrite.
Excuse me, Mayor Barajas.
I did have a speaker card from Laura Schult, but I do believe she left.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's for the record.
Thank you.
Go ahead.
Thank you, Mayor.
Madam Mayor.
So I think if we were to pass this tonight, it has to come back in February.
Could we then exclude the auto auction, specific auto auction?
We could at that point, yes.
So before I give my position a little bit, and what else it just is, I'll give a little
bit of history to our city and give Tom some credit when the city first incorporated Tom
intentionally removed these uses from our land uses.
At the time, two council members at the time added the CUP processes and created where we
are today.
We're now trying to fix that, and I think our community sees that, I think our, my colleagues
see that.
So I just wanted to understand how we got here, why we got here.
And there was some foresight at some point to try to stop where we are from happening.
I think my recommendation would be to approve the ordinance and the urgency ordinance as
is when it comes back in February, because I don't think any of us have seen the auto
auction and what the proposal is.
So I don't know if there's a way to share more information, it does sound like something
that I would be open to excluding, no one else, but I would like to know more information
about it and what it is, if that is fair.
They haven't, they haven't concluded their plans, they came to me to try to get some perspective
of what the city might, you know, be looking at that property, you know, what kind of uses
might end up being there that might get an approval down the road.
So my recommendation at the end of the day to them was to kind of regroup a presentation
to council wanted and to council to those projects, which makes sure I suppose that they get
their chance to continue on their path.
I don't think that this is something they're going to come back tomorrow or next week with
all of a sudden we've got the great idea, I think it's going to take them a little.
So it'd probably be like a year, right, when they come, it'd probably take them a year
if they go to the whole process.
Well, it depends.
I mean, if they come up with some kind of conceptual plan, then they could bring that
in at any time and council can give them constructive criticisms as to what the plus
is and minus is that, you know, each of us see on that project and then they can go
back before it goes to planning commission and then comes back to us for approvals down
the road.
It basically cuts out the extra six months to a year of not knowing if council's going
to just deny it at the end of the day because council hasn't laid in on it yet, which
has happened on projects that we've had in the past.
It gets to council after two years.
Council doesn't like it.
Planning commission didn't get all the questions answered necessarily or get the project to
where council was comfortable with it.
So you have projects that people spend a lot of time, a lot of money, just at the end of
the day get a denial.
So the point of bringing these types of developments to the forefront of council early in the planning
stages gives the developer time to make modifications to their plans that would be more
feasible to our residents and to council.
So I just, I mean, at the end of the day, they don't have a plan 100% right now.
I just don't want them to have to stop trying to create something.
Again, since it has to come back to us to be approved anyway by excluding them from this
moratorium, it doesn't exclude them from proceeding with their plan.
And that's all I'm just saying is maybe we should give them a chance to do that.
And if I could add to that, that's exactly my understanding as well, council member Bergson.
But in addition to that, they do have a formal application in for their current use.
So there actually is something that is being processed right now.
So in addition to everything that council member Bergson dedicated.
If that's the sticking point, I'd be okay with that only exception.
That only exception?
So no other exception.
So we have three applicants and we're only including one as the exception.
And that's we, I think honestly, if that is a sticking point, that's fine.
But honestly, I'd rather just do it to all of them because even if we don't to this site,
we're basically putting them through the gauntlet of the reason why we're trying to do this.
They don't know if they can go through the whole gambit and then we'll deny them anyway.
I think the whole point of the moratorium is to give it to the planning commission,
give it to the stakeholders, whether that's private industry and the public.
Take the time, look at what we actually want, where we want it, and everyone knows the rules.
Even if you give this one the exception right now, they are still going to go in blind to the current system.
Go through the process, put workshops together, apply to the planning commission.
And petition maybe denied it.
And petition they get denied anyway.
So this process is still going to going to take about a year.
I mean, it's ever take about a year.
That's right.
Okay, most of these permit, the permit process and everything that follows through with it and,
you know, planning, it's not an overnight process.
It's not an overnight approval.
So, I don't know, I believe if we're going to do this, we got to stop it in the moratorium service.
I mean, this is to benefit our city.
We do need to start identifying the problem areas,
identifying the issues that we have here with that respect or in that industry.
And we also need to figure out how to mitigate these issues.
I don't agree with giving an exclusion to one and not all three that are there.
And for me, I would rather start the moratorium or the urgency ordinance establishing the moratorium
and it be across the board.
I agree with that also.
I would also ask, maybe we can find out how far along other people are in the process.
I mean, if they're in the final stage, well, I mean, if you're, sure, we can certainly,
when we bring this back to the city council, we can certainly provide each of the projects
that we see are currently on tap in the pipeline and how far into that they are.
So we can certainly provide that.
Okay. Any other questions or comments from council?
No, I think you covered it.
I completely agree.
I don't think anybody should have an exclusion because then we're going to have other people
coming in with the same thing.
So we're going to do it.
Let's just do it all across the board.
And either way, we come back with a item in February, correct?
And from there on, we proceed to either extend or go a different route.
Sure. You can make that alteration at that time.
Absolutely. And yeah, what that is, is we're bringing, so the moratorium would be in effect
for that 45 days.
And what the reason we'd be bringing that back to you is, okay, we are now going to extend
it.
And if we want to make some alterations to it, then that would be in effect over that extended
period of time.
Okay.
With that said, and no other comments from council looking for a motion.
I move to approve.
Second.
All in favor?
Wait, wait.
I need to read the title because it's an ordinance.
Sorry.
Go ahead here.
This would be an urgency ordinance of the city council of the city of Herupa Valley, California
imposing a temporary moratorium pursuant to government code section 65858 on the expansion
or establishment of truck intensive uses in the industrial park IP manufacturing service
commercial MSC manufacturing medium M manufacturing heavy MH mineral resources, MR and mineral
resources and related manufacturing, uh, MRA zones looking for a motion to approve the
recommended actions move to approve.
Second.
All in favor?
Aye.
Any opposed?
Okay.
Recommended action passes five to zero item E approval of five new classifications and updated
salary schedule four twenty twenty through twenty twenty one.